so last Thursday we were treated with a
leaked toy description of Avengers four
that revealed that there is possibly a
second villain in a vendor's four here's
what the description read the Asgardian
Thor wields the mighty storm breaker in
his battle against new foes rocket teams
up with a new crew to guard the galaxy
from an even greater threat so this
description makes it pretty clear that
there is another villain coming into
Avengers four who is a greater threat
than Thanos so the question is who could
come in right now and be an even greater
threat than Thanos well the most widely
believed running Avengers for title
right now could reveal who this new
villain is I'm still giving away copies
of infinity war and ant-man and the wasp
on blu-ray all you have to do to enter
the giveaway is subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero so right now the most common
believe title for Avengers 4 is Avengers
annihilation this title comes from
sources that are deemed most reliable so
it is widely believed that this will in
fact be the title many people think well
this makes sense because Thanos
annihilated half of the universe but
Fanus is done now he's succeeded he
doesn't want to wipe out the whole
entire universe just half of it well
what if the title isn't actually
referring to Thanos as we learned from
this leaked description there's going to
be a second villain in Avengers 4 that's
an even greater threat than Thanos and I
believe the villain is kind of stated in
the title annihilation I think that the
second villain in Avengers 4 is going to
be an eyeless a nihilist actually fits
in the current story of the MCU
extremely well right now and introducing
Annihilus in Avengers 4 could actually
set up the future
MC use characters such as the Fantastic
Four the Silver Surfer and Galactus
Annihilus is of the Tainan species and
although he is initially a very weak
being he's also incredibly intelligent
due to a mutation the Titans come from
an antimatter universe called the
negative zone thanks to advanced TYIN
and technology Annihilus increases his
intellect and strength and goes on to
create what's called a cosmic control
rod the cosmic control rod was a very
powerful artifact that
haled from the negative zone this
extremely powerful artifact gives a
nihilist incalculable powers and
abilities Annihilus becomes obsessed
with survival and he sets out to destroy
any other living being who threatens his
existence
Annihilus can be introduced into the MCU
and Avengers 4 in a number of ways and
truthfully it would be quite easy to
introduce him in Avengers 4 for starters
one of the first things that Annihilus
does is invade the Microverse the
Microverse is what we know in the MCU as
the quantum realm due to ownership
issues they were not allowed to use the
word Microverse in the MCU so they came
up with a quantum realm this would be a
very easy way to introduce Annihilus
especially because Avengers 4 is set to
emphasize the quantum realm a lot one
way to really integrate Annihilus into
the story of Avengers 4 is to look at
the comic story annihilation in the
annihilation story Annihilus discovers
the opposing force the opposing force is
the negative zones counterpart to the
power cosmic and the power cosmic is a
vast source of limitless godly cosmic
energy and power usually wielded by
Galactus having the opposing force he
enters the Marvel Universe through a
portal known as the crunch with his army
the annihilation wave denial Asian wave
goes on to destroy many worlds and many
heroes and then Annihilus desires the
power cosmic
Annihilus ends up teaming up with Thanos
and they both end up capturing Galactus
Annihilus ends up using Galactus as a
weapon harnessing the power cosmic
Thanos actually ends up fearing a
nihilist because he's become so powerful
ultimately Galactus ends up being
released and defeats Annihilus so how
can they work this story into the MCU
and Avengers 4 well after Avengers
infinity war Thanos is left in a
permanently damaged and weakened state
and since a nihilist seeks out to
destroy all opposing threats to him he
could take this opportunity to not only
attack Thanos but the Avengers as well
and if he comes in with the opposing
force and the annihilation wave army he
would definitely be a greater threat
than Thanos and the comics pretty much
everybody goes up against an eyeless the
Fantastic Four the Silver Surfer
Galactus and some of his
old's the Avengers guardians of the
galaxy Ronan the accuser decree the
scroll and Thanos so it's a really easy
way to introduce him into Avengers 4 in
the MCU and this also opens it up to
introduce the Silver Surfer
the Fantastic Four and Galactus in the
future MCU movies and in the comics he
actually comes into battle with Marvel
and the Kree in the scroll so they could
actually somehow introduce him or
mention him in Captain Marvel so again
there are so many ways that they could
introduce Annihilus in Avengers 4 and it
seems to line up with everything we know
so far from the title being annihilation
to a second threat that is more powerful
than Thanos from the Kree and scroll
being incorporated and to set up the
future of the MCU so as of right now
Annihilus is mostly believed to be the
new villain in Avengers 4 but what do
you all think let me know your thoughts
on this theory in the comments below and
don't forget to subscribe comment and
like the video so you can enter the
giveaway and stay up to date with
everything relating to Avengers 4 as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]